he's the six trillion dollar man big
government joe biden is promising an
avalanche of new spending on top of his
massive stimulus plan
biden wants to expand the role of the
federal government in just about
every aspect of your life
american families plan guarantees four
additional years of public education
for every person in america universal
high quality pre-school
for three and four-year-olds not day
care pre-school
we can't stop there we're going to add
two years of community college on top of
that
the american family's plan is going to
finally provide up to 12 weeks of paid
and medical leave paid family medical
leave
plan on giving tax breaks to the working
class folks
and making everybody pay their fair
share
all right juan here's why republicans
are so suspicious of democrats pushing
socialism
because republicans are the only thing
standing in the way of democrats and
socialism
every time you guys get power you add a
new program you give more free stuff and
it never ends
wow you know i i have the other view
here i remember that the economy
absolutely took off under bill clinton
for example
i remember that when barack obama got in
he had to rescue the economy
i don't think there's any question about
that and i think that the economy
experienced tremendous
consistent growth under obama not as
fast as i know you
jesse would have liked but it was
consistent uh
and i think that right now when we talk
about this
biden program as socialist i you know i
think i've
said this several times so i pardoned me
for repeating it but
since joe biden was elected on this
agenda
the stock market's up 20 percent so that
means that the investor class the ceos
the bankers
as well as the unions and workers all
say this is a good plan we don't have a
problem with it
the stock market says let's go baby you
know the gdp
says let's take off but you know
specifics of the plan like things like
universal pre-k
the things you know things that mean
something to me like you know paid leave
like and should mean something to you
you just had a baby you got a week off
you know we have paid leave joe biden
says in a pro-worker statement
it shouldn't just be for people like you
and me it should be for hourly workers
as well
that's good for the american economy
that's that's true in other developed
countries why not here
i support paid leave for you too juan
dana perino i think what i was
getting at there is that is that
republicans are the only one
pumping the brakes here on democrats
expanding government
every time they get power they want to
just spend more and grow the government
more and more and more so we're the only
ones stopping them
if we weren't here it would just be a
full socialist takeover
and i think this is actually a more
useful direction that this conversation
is going beyond just the
eye-popping numbers that he wants to
spend it's how does he want to spend it
um why it's like a whole different shift
of
having government be in control of even
more things
how has that worked out in the past you
look at europe um in terms of
uh innovation and economic growth um one
of the reasons that their militaries are
so um
basically weak and hobbled is because
they have
all of these entitlements that they
continue to build
to grow and that spending never stops
it's also a problem here you know
the rest of our budget gets squeezed
because we never want to deal with
those programs like social security and
medicare
and that's true of both parties but
right now i think what you're seeing is
that
i think that joe biden's agenda
it's already stalling out and i'll tell
you why i think that he
went on a big trip yesterday to virginia
he was trying to sell his american
uh jobs plan not a blip jesse
and you already have democrats who are
in tough races in 2022 saying
yeah i don't think we're going to be for
that and so with the with the very small
margins that they have
they're not going to be able to just
muscle this through and the longer it
hangs out there and gets more scrutiny
like what we're doing right now
the more likely it is that it sort of
dies on the vine or at least gets paired
way way back
you think that's true katie you think
the democrats are scared to go along
with joe's plan because they're just
going to get shellacked
next election
i think some of that may be true but i
also believe that if the senate
if the senate were more heavily democrat
meaning it wasn't 50 50 and joe manchin
and christian cinema didn't have as much
power as they do
that they would be more than happy to
push through a lot of these things so i
think it's more of a senate issue
than it would be in the house um but on
this issue of
whose phone is ringing
just kidding on this issue of
it it was why it was one
okay so on this issue of the free
college right community college
joe biden's pushing this at the same
time you have these school districts
across the country saying
no more advanced math so free college
but
you don't get to actually take advanced
courses that may get you to college or
get you a scholarship to college
the other thing about this is the the
grave the
the cradle to the grave socialism this
is always sold as americans having more
opportunity right paid leave will give
more women more opportunity
but it's actually the opposite it means
you have less freedom you have fewer
choices and the private sector gets
completely suffocated because they can't
afford
these policies we're seeing it right now
with unemployment these restaurants they
can't hire enough people
because people aren't going back to work
because they're making more money from
the government than they are
actually going to work and so the
opposite of these programs is always
the truth of less freedom fewer choices
and more expenses than
is being sold by president biden right
now
last word goes to greg gutfeld uh just
to point out that the gdp and stocks
aren't reacting to
cho's tax plan they're reacting to the
pandemic shutdown that is
reopening you always get this is just
eternally true
you always get big gains in an economy
gdp in stock market
after huge losses because you have a lot
of turf
to expand to grow until it levels off
and then the growth gets smaller and
smaller and smaller
yes i'm an economist um here's the
problem with
here's the problem with this debate it's
not the 1980s anymore
if you call something socialism it's not
going to persuade a population that has
no idea what it means
no one's being educated anymore about
socialism
they don't know anything about ussr they
haven't read any history books
or world history on socialism they don't
know what it means so cradle to grave
government
actually sounds pretty good it's like
wow that's awesome
that means the government's going to be
with me until i die
i don't have to worry about anything and
the thing is the reason why they think
that way and it's natural is because no
one's explained to them
succinctly the trade-offs obviously this
comes with the price
and you need to tell them okay if you
turn everything over to government
number one
you can't afford it the country goes
broke and when there's an emergency
number two let's say like a war your
military will be
uh will be hogtied uh you the goods and
services will not meet the standards of
private industry
so what you pay for i.e amtrak or the
mail
is nothing like what fedex could do so
it all over time goes to hell in terms
of quality
the individual is less inclined to um
achieve greatness
if they know if they don't have to
they're still gonna
gonna get a free meal and a free x and a
free y you don't have to work so hard
and then lastly you just run out of rich
people right
because because either they go fro they
go broke or they leave
so we that needs we need to do it
go ahead sorry or you could just do this
you could just say big tax and spending
liberals are racist there you go that's
that's what the democrats do just call
it racism
that's a good point that's much easier
that would have saved me hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else